c'est faut-il tout pardonner aux grandes
stars vous allez comprendre
avec ce sujet évidemment michael jackson
qui aurait jay pédophiles avec depardieu
qui se raccorde pas avec poutine qui a
tendance un peu être un peu de champ
mais avec la tchétchénie les homosexuels
bref bardot qui vont tellement écrit des
bouquins un peu dégueulasse
regardez le sujet et fut derrière
faut-il tout pardonner aux grandes stars
on en parle chaque jour la polémique
enfle un peu plus diffusé hier sur m6 le
documentaire living neverland qui accuse
michael jackson de pédophilie de façon
accablante sème le trouble
ces deux hommes wade et james raconte
avoir été violée par la star lors ce
qu'ils étaient adolescents
derrière ces photos donc la possible
horreur
dix ans après sa mort michael jackson
est donc en passe de devenir la star la
plus détestée du monde
un boycott qui fait hurler ses fans mais
si les accusations de pédophilie sont
réels faut-il vraiment défendre michael
jackson une question que l'on pourrait
poser aussi au sujet de gérard depardieu
qui clame tranquillement son amitié avec
le président le plus controversé du
monde bladimir poutine au sujet aussi
des propos racistes de brigitte bardot
qui traite les réunionnais de population
dégénéré imprégné de cannibalisme des
comportements scandaleux mais les foules
ne s'indigne pas pas plus que quand dany
boon johnny ou florent pagny s'exile
tranquillement pour ne pas payer leurs
impôts en france alors certes elles sont
très populaires mais faut-il tout
pardonner aux grandes stars
faut-il tout pardonner aux grandes stars
donc évidemment c'est la question qu'on
s'est posée j'aimerais vraiment répond
totalement à tour de table je fais le
con mais ça a bien thomas arrivés en
deux ans je serai comme toi j'aurai des
loupes triple foyer je sais pas comment
vous avez un peu floue quoi assez mieux
d'ailleurs
oui bien sûr alors faut-il tout part de
nos grandes stars vous avez vu ce sujet
oui non j'ai un nom pour sébastien
vallier là faut pas tout pardonner aux
grandes stars pourquoi ah bah non parce
que si on parle par exemple pour
certains artistes de pédophilie je vois
pas comment on peut pardonner ça encore
une fois si vous parlez michael jackson
je n'ai pas tiré de l'eau après on peut
parler aussi de viols d'évasion fiscale
enfin voilà minority s'ils sont des
petits détails des petites erreurs je
veux bien mais quand on est arrivé à des
choses très très grave non on peut pas
pardonner je vous pose des questions
aussi un peu plus brutale et vous dites
fut non quant au quotidien reçoit par
exemple depardieu qui est un mot ça
qu'on adore et que depardieu est très
aimé lire poutine
je veux pas m poutine à doha sera
dangereux en français signée encore
beaucoup d'homosexuels que là bas les
homosexuels c'est mal vu on sait les
massacres en date s'est uni on va au
c'est tout ça il l'a condamné et on
reçoit depardieu condamine pour ça je me
souviens aussi d'alain delon qui avait
dit un jour je ne vote pas pour lui mais
jean marie le pen est mon meilleur ami
le fameux le pen qui elle est fêlé
durafour crématoire
bah je pose juste la question fin j'ai
rien qui vous choque dans tout ça donc
choqué pas choquer choqué non je ne suis
pas choqué pardon c'est quoi la question
vous parle il faut pardonner parce que
une grande star justement si les grandes
stars et des masques à l'impossibilité
parce qu'elle est différente parce
qu'elle a dans le lait dans le bon comme
dans le mauvais les différents des
autres sinon elle serait pas une star
maintenant elle fera un quidam moyen et
du coup je dis pas qu'il faut pardonner
dans le sens où ils dament ans ils ont
violé tué et c'est me for n'est pas juge
quoi il se lie pays d'un côté mais après
tout il peut tout pardonner ses regrets
continue à regarder leurs films quand
une écouter leurs chansons continuer at
à lui signer à regarder les films de
brigitte bardot etc
si on en a envie on le sait à moi je
redonne mon exemple se désole j'adore
depardieu mais pardon je suis pour les
locales je suis reparti pour ceux qui ne
connaissent me dire qu'en russie ait des
gens dans ces pays des gens qui meurent
encore mais j'ai bien dans la carrière
que je me rate avec depardieu home town
connaître à garder plus long terme à ces
personnes parce que je pensais comme
l'udc il ya dix quinze ans ouais tu es
jeune et aujourd'hui je me dis je vais
aller plus loin je pense qu'il faut
ajouter tous les connards du métier il
ya un moment où le seuil d'accord il ya
tellement de gens qui sont
en sarre qui sont des gens ont duré
lemay demandé jean épouvantable j'en
peux plus il ya une omerta depuis des
années ces gamins s'il faut rien dire
maintenant je vais pas dire mille fois
rien dire moi et je parle pas
spécialement effectivement deux cas très
graves de politique étrangère pédophiles
mais il ya des gens stop on alors vous
dites non il faut faut pas tout pardonné
à part de regarder qu'à valider les
faits et puis un an après la découverte
m
évasion fiscale tromperie qu'il a raison
on ne va pas tout sur mathieu je suis
pas pour qu'on boycotte leur offre un
verre je suis pour le sais quoi mais
attention alors alors pas tous en même
temps qui n'a pas parlé myriam moi moi
en fait quand j'ai dit que j'ai goûté
sinon à vous pour vous faire part de
notre part on peut pas tout pardonner
après c'est aussi une question de
subjectivité enfin je veux dire le ont
peut aimer l'oeuvre d'un artiste est pas
apprécié l'homme je sais que vous
n'aimez pas ce genre de phrase un peu
bateau de mais en même temps c'est une
réalité on va pas s'arrêter d'écouté
michael jackson parce qu'il ya des
soupçons de pédophilie
on va pas arrêter de alors je sais que
ça avait extrêmement choqué ce que je
dis mais c'est comme tous les gens qui
écoutent bertrand cantat hockey comme
d'une excuse tout extrême je donne un
exemple je veux dire vous et extrême il
n'importe quoi c'est comme si je vous
disais par exemple mein kampf d'adolf
hitler était un très très grand
dynamisme et je n'aime pas la personne
mais là c'est pareil
l'impact d'adolphe hitler sur la
littérature n'est pas le même que je
suis michael jackson sur les prix ce que
je veux dire j'ai pris un étendard mp3 y
est ce qu'on peut séparer l'oeuvre de la
personne absolument pas voilà ce qu'a
pris à moi je prenais l'exemple en
coulisses qui vous a fait rire mais est
ce qu'on dirait d'ing nanne emile louis
qui était chauffeur de bus c est un
tueur en série
c'est pas grave vous savez c'est un
excellent chauffeur de m
[Musique]
la batterie non mais c'est pas vrai dans
le cas de richard wagner était un
antisémite aux maisons et toutes au même
niveau et rien n'est gravé n'ont rien de
grave c'est pas vrai en hommage aux
anciennes bâtisses en même temps c'est
pas vrai wagner était raciste antisémite
épouvantable son oeuvre musicale
extraordinaire céline est un écrivain
qui écrit des choses abject mais qui
avait fait également voyage au bout de
la nuit dans lequel il n'y a rien de
raciste antisémite
donc évidemment qu'on peut faire le
distinguo dans ce cas là encore sortir
aussi coco chanel toutes les femmes à
leurs portes sourient coco chanel
pendant la guerre avec les allemands
c'est pas elle avait une tendance à
lever le bras droit la plupart de nos
stars vous avez dit non voir comment
encore une fois vous êtes très avec nous
faut-il tout part de nos stars vous avez
dit non à non faut pas tout pardonner
my-channels rachel les stars ce sont des
humains comme vous et moi donc voilà
avec leurs faiblesses avec leurs vis
avec et voilà et non il faut pas tout
leur pardonner ça reste des humains
c'est pas des dieux ils sont pas
intouchables
j'avais un sujet faut-il tout pardonner
aux footballeurs
madouni berda vous avez dit oui au tout
part de nos stars mois en fait je trouve
que ces gens là ils sont aussi sous le
feu des projecteurs tout le temps il ya
plein d amalgames qui sont faits on voit
des gens qui peuvent fréquenter une
personne et parce qu il le fréquente
cette personne est mal mais il n'est pas
censé tout connaître tout savoir et
c'est donc les ppc du trail avec le
cirque on parle de pédophilie bien sûr
on est d'accord c'est c est ce là on est
dans un extrait
mais sinon sur le reste franchement je
trouve que des fois ça va un peu trop
loin c'est des gens qui sont jugés
constamment mais oui il faut maintenant
qu'ils contrôlent aussi avec qui samir
est très peu de temps à dernier mot très
court daniel on vient de voir une photo
florent pagny l'exil fiscal c'est
évidemment mis alors en exergue parce
que c'est des choses énormes et il est
connu mais est ce que nous on ne connaît
pas on n'a pas un ami qui a fraudé
indien je suis désolé je leur ai dit
c'est pas possible
le sondage ça m'intéresse vraiment
d'abord la vie des gens faut-il tout
part de nos grandes stars oui 11% non
89%
j'ai fait un sans faute